Stan Lee is one of the most recognizable figures
in pop culture.
Not only did he co-create of many of the world's
most popular superheroes, he frequently appears
alongside them in movies, TV shows, and comic
books.
Here are some our favorite times that Stan
was the man.
Stan the supervillain
Stan and collaborator Jack Kirby have been
super-involved with their creations since
the 1950s, when they used to cosplay for their
own comic book covers.
But they outdid themselves with Fantastic
Four #10, which stars the pair being forced
to assist Dr. Doom in a scheme to defeat Reed
Richards.
Luckily, Reed saves the day in the end.
Stan the superhero
In 1978, Stan went from fighting the Fantastic
Four to becoming team leader.
What If?
#11 explores what might've happened if Stan
and the rest of the original Marvel creative
team—Jack Kirby, Sol Brodsky, and Flo Steinberg—had
become the Fantastic Four.
Spoiler alert: not only do they defeat the
evil aliens, they do it while putting out
comics about their own adventures.
Leave it to Stan to save the world in his
spare time...
Stan the superhero: part two
One of the coolest Stan Lee cameos came in
Disney's Big Hero 6.
Based loosely on a Marvel comic that Stan
didn't have anything to do with, the film
paid tribute to Marvel's living mascot with
a post-credits scene revealing he's actually
the father of superhero wannabe Fred.
Even better?
Stan is secretly a superhero himself.
Stan the librarian
Maybe the funniest of all of Lee's many movie
cameos was in The Amazing Spider-Man.
Spidey and the Lizard trash an entire library,
but neither of them can lay a finger on Stan,
who's oblivious to their tussle thanks to
his sick Beats By Dre.
Stan the wedding crasher
Considering Stan Lee co-created the Fantastic
Four, you’d think he’d get an invite to
Reed and Sue’s wedding.
But Stan actually had to crash the wedding
not once, but twice: first in the comics,
accompanied by Jack Kirby, and then in the
movies in Fantastic Four: Rise of the Silver
Surfer.
He was shown the door both times.
“Ah, invitation sir.
Um, I should be on that list.
Name.
Stan Lee.
Yeah uh, nice try buddy, nice try.
No really...?”
Stan the guru
Throughout Kevin Smith's 1995 cul- classic
Mallrats, Jason Lee’s character Brodie talks
about Stan Lee's awesomeness—just like we’re
doing now.
At a key moment, Stan suddenly shows up and
delivers a rousing inspirational speech that
turns Brodie around, allowing him to save
the day.
If only it were that easy to summon Stan when
you needed him.
We’ll just have to settle for his doll instead.
Stan the Man
Given that he's pushing a hundred, Stan is
like everyone's grandpa.
That's why it was so surprising to see him
show up in a strip club in Deadpool.
“Give it up for Chastity.”
In real life, Stan is anything but a player:
he and his wife Joan have been married for
seven decades.
But Stan's strip club appearance is just one
of several cameos showing Stan surrounded
by ladies.
In Iron Man,Tony Stark accidentally confuses
Stan for Playboy creator Hugh Hefner, while
in Guardians of the Galaxy, we see Stan working
his mojo.
Guardians director James Gunn originally had
a different idea for Stan's cameo, though:
he wanted Stan to be shown in one of the Collector's
cages, only to have his head blown off when
the Collector's museum is leveled by an explosion.
Now that’s going out…
“Like a boss, approve memo, like a boss.”
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave a comment to let us know which Stan
Lee moment you think was his most
epic...